I'm really happy to be here I've met
some amazing people at this conference
and I just followed like a bunch of
amazing speakers so we'll see how close
I can get to that at this talk but
um yeah so we're just gonna jump right
in uh a quick about me as Taylor said I
was just at Squarespace uh left there a
couple weeks ago I'm starting a new role
uh next month but right now this is a
fun time to be at this conference
because I don't have a job the vendors
have nothing to sell me because I don't
know what their stack is
and I say that with love being
previously a vendor
um a little bit about me I'm in New York
City I grew up in Florida I like
outdoorsy stuff uh there are no
mountains in Florida so I'm happy to be
in a state that has mountains now and
I'm really passionate about volleyball
it's the only sport I'm not terrible at
you can find me anywhere on the internet
at
r-i-k-t-u-r-r uh that's Twitter LinkedIn
any social medias any websites also
Gmail if you want to email me and ask me
any questions
um so yeah so I was almost uh recently
at Squarespace I worked a lot on the
analytics platform so that encompassed
uh tools like bigquery DBT looker uh and
airflow primarily also some trino and my
role was a as a lead on the on the
software side basically making sure that
the teams of analysts and analytics
Engineers that we had there could do
their job in the most efficient ways
possible and I was kind of building
stuff behind the scenes and you're going
to see a couple examples of some things
that I built and learned along the way
and that's kind of how this talk came up
because we used DBT I had to learn about
DVT and I had to build stuff on top of
it and had to go really deep so I'm
hoping to share that with all of you
a quick intro into DBT because actually
surprisingly there's not a huge DBT
Presence at the conference here maybe
it's kind of you know I know there's uh
the keynote letters a couple folks from
DBT here
um for a lot of people it's a assumption
that everybody knows DBT for some people
they have may have never used it so I'm
curious just because I can actually ask
you now because we're at an in-person
talk can you raise your hand if you've
heard of DBT
use it at your job
cool uh have you ever extended DBT or
built something weird on top of it Okay
cool so this is going to be going
towards that ladder end of the route so
hopefully we can increase those numbers
of hands for the next next round
um but for those of you who don't know
um the way I like to think about DBT is
that it brings software engineering
fundamentals to SQL based data pipelines
and there's an asterisk because now you
know it does python also but we're just
going to keep it up SQL for now
um and so some of the things that come
out of the box that makes this really
helpful when you're thinking about this
as a software engineering project is
that there's like a project structure
that's enforced and there are ideas
about it and you may not agree but at
least everybody is using the same thing
SQL has a challenge that it's really
hard to reuse components right it can be
very verbose so there's ginger
templating for you to be able to reuse
um
portions of the SQL so that we can make
the code easier to read a really nice
big part of DBT is the environment
separation so you can kind of do
development in one place in your
Warehouse in kind of a scratch area and
then deploy the same exact code into
production as well as this project
structure enforces good testimony
documentation practices and really DBT
burst this idea and field of analytics
engineering so when we're talking about
DBT today I'm going to focus on the open
source part DBT core because that's what
we use the Squarespace
um and here's a quick here's a quick
just like if you haven't seen DBT on the
left side there's a SQL file and that's
kind of the basis of everything that
happens in DBT a single SQL file is
called a model and it comprises a select
statement which creates a table in your
Warehouse so DBT
um you know that's kind of like the
building block right and so you can see
here we have some ctes we have some
things but then we have some weird curly
braces right and so that's where the
templating starts to come in at the
bottom we can see a for Loop that'll
kind of like write a bunch of columns
for us and then you can see these kind
of like ref statements that'll help tie
different models together so you can say
one model depends on another one that
one has to be run and created first and
then this other one can reference it on
the right hand side you see a yaml file
which corresponds to this model and this
is where all the testing and
documentation comes in you have the name
of the table the description
um all the columns enumerated out in
certain tests like the primary key has
to be unique and different things and so
this is mostly what you're doing in
writing when you're writing DPT
as far as running DBT DBT comes with a
command line interface and you it's a
package that you install but then you
you're on this command line interface
and as long as you're in the directory
of your project you can run a bunch of
commands to do different things with
your project DBT build will basically
execute your entire project so that'll
run all the models
it'll test them it'll do documentation
for you it produces like a doc site and
all of those things so but actually
what's happening behind the scenes you
see all this running and everything
right what DBT is doing is it's sending
that SQL statement to your data
warehouse whether that's postgres
snowflake bigquery any database system
that DBT supports or their Community
adapters for it and then it's not
running that original SQL statement that
I showed you right because that wasn't
actually a real SQL those curly braces
would fail if you try to run it in
bigquery it compiles a real SQL file
which it then runs against the warehouse
so this is an example of that compiled
one now you can see it creating a table
you can see the real table name from
that reference that I I showed you
earlier and that's you know the
generally the idea of what DBT does this
is actually uh this compiled SQL file is
not part of the code that's in your
project it actually gets generated and
that brings us to DBT artifacts so you
know we talked about DPT what it is
um artifacts are things that the DPT
code produces you don't write this code
you don't check this into your version
control but it's something that happens
kind of on the Fly
um and I I think I should have put the
slide before we got to the artifacts
thing we were talking about the project
so I showed you a SQL file showed you a
yaml file here's what the structure of a
typical DBT project looks like we're
using the classical jaffle shops project
and uh which is kind of just like the
hello world for DBT if you can call
anything classical I mean DBT is not
even that old yet
um but you can see here that there's a
there's a dbtproject.yaml file which I'm
showing you the contents there that's
the configuration of your project
there's a bunch of settings that we
don't need to go into here and then you
have a models folder which has all those
SQL files and those yaml files and
documentation and such and so this is
all the code that you're writing you're
checking into your branch for your
that's that's for your project
the artifacts like I mentioned are the
components that get produced when you
execute anything on your DBT project so
they're basically files that describe
your project but you didn't write them
so every typically this goes in the
Target folder and you're not again
you're not writing these files these are
just the exhaust of DBT needs to do some
stuff to figure out what it's going to
run and this is the exhaustive when that
happens and you can check out the docs
to see like what all the different
artifacts are there's a bunch of
different ones but we're going to focus
today on the one I don't know if you can
see it like the seventh one down or
something called manifest dot Json and
that's the Manifest so we're going to
talk about today
so uh what is it I'm going to let you
read this because this is copied and
pasted from the DVT doc site and I don't
like reading slides so I'll give you a
moment for that
on the right side is basically like a
minimized preview of what this manifests
uh Json file looks like and I'll talk
about that more when everybody's done
reading
cool okay so like my definition of it
the quick kind of easy way is that it's
the Manifest file is a machine readable
file that has everything that you need
to know about your DBT project or it
describes your DPT project everything
about your DBZ project in one place
and you know we can see here that
there's some metadata there's node
sources like I'm not going to explain
all the individual pieces of this but if
you're already using DBT open up this
Json file and there's a tip it comes
just formatted as like one line and you
know get some like Json formatter if
you're in Sublime you can install a
plugin called pretty Json or if you're
in vs code there's like hotkeys to Auto
format your Json and then you're going
to be able to kind of read it better but
then honestly just reading through this
single file gives you a lot of
information about what's really going on
behind the scenes in DBT and what things
are configurable in there
um a little bit more about this manifest
file uh like I said it's typically
written to that Target folder you can
control that setting and it's updated on
pretty much anytime you run DBT space
something because anytime you're running
DBT you're going to do something with
your project and it's going to update
this manifest file and if you're going
to use this is that's kind of the goal
of this presentation which we'll get
into
um you have to understand that if you
change any code in your DBT project the
Manifest file doesn't automatically get
updated right you have to run some kind
of DVD command and then it will update
it and it's always going to up the
Manifest file is always going to have
your whole project even if you say like
DBT run just like model one two three
it's still going to have everything
because it needs to know the the full
kind of like Global spec of your project
even if it's going to execute one
component of it
okay so this is
um that same sequel I think on the left
right and then on the right side I'm
showing you an example of what the
Manifest file looks like for this
specific model uh in this case they're
called nodes like there's you know
models seeds are all kind of nodes
um but I'm going to highlight just kind
of one aspect again you can dig into the
Manifest yourself to see the individual
pieces but for instance I'm using this
ref statement right to say that this
customers model depends on another
Upstream model called stage underscore
orders and we can see that we're inside
of our customers uh model in that Json
file and we can see that there's a
depends on key a few lines down and then
inside of that there's another section
called nodes and you can see a list of
three items so those are all of the
nodes that are Upstream of this current
model so
if that information is important to you
or your system you can start to use that
in kind of like in some ways hopefully
I'm starting to get some gears turning
on like how you can like extract
information about your DBT project from
the Manifest file
uh and this whole talk is all about
using the Manifest file right and so and
what do I mean by that it's basically
like I said it's a machine readable file
so you're going to write some kind of
code to process this file and do
something either automatically on a
scheduler or so on if you're a person
that needs to see your project you can
just go to the regular folder and look
at all the the contents of your DPT
project right you don't have to look at
the Json file but in this case you know
it can be a python script something in a
CI Tool uh so on and so the goal of this
presentation here is to kind of just
give you a background into the Manifest
file tell you what it is so that you
know what's running under the hood but
also mostly to inspire you to use the
Manifest file in any sort of
applications at your organization
I'm gonna the rest of the talk will be
kind of giving examples of that but
hopefully like you know the best
conference talks I think is like you'll
get like one little little nugget of an
idea of something and then you go back
next week go back to work and then start
kind of like tinkering on that hopefully
you can get at least some kind of ideas
from this talk
um so as far as using the Manifest file
I have just like a python script here
really simple just to illustrate it
um you know we're running the kind of
bash commands from DBT and like I
mentioned you always want to make sure
that you're updating your manifest file
if you're going to read it so in this
case we're running DBT depth DBT compile
to make sure the Manifest gets updated
and then using uh Json load statement
right to load that Json file and then on
the right I have a rebel open here just
kind of calling this function pulling
out the Manifest that comes back as a
dictionary right so I go into the nodes
I go into the particular like key that I
was showing you on the other screen and
so now I can get that back inside of my
uh python function now
cool okay like I said the rest of this
talk now is going to talk about
different applications and use cases of
ways that you can use the Manifest file
so there's a few categories here some of
them are going to be heavier than others
but we'll start off with airflow
orchestration because I think this is
one of the heavier sides but one of the
really powerful use cases of being able
to read machine readable versions of
your DBT project
um and uh this is going to be a mix of
stuff that I've built at Squarespace and
stuff out in the community I'd say
probably about like half and half so
I'll make sure to to indicate when it's
something that I've built versus
something that's kind of already out
there this is something that inspired
something that I built which we'll talk
about in a second
um but there's an article out there uh
from astronomer and some other folks
about kind of creating airflow dags
based on DBT projects and so uh
basically what this does is it makes uh
if you're not familiar with airflow
right airflow is an orchestration tool
it also uses the concept of dags and
graphs where you can have a task that
runs and then another task after it and
then the second task might depend on the
first task and then you schedule those
to kind of run together if you think
about the way that your DPT project runs
with multiple different models that also
depend on each other it's the same kind
of Paradigm they call them both dags and
so the idea here is that if you wanted
to schedule your DBT project execution
in airflow you could just have a bash
operator task and say DB BT build and
then it runs in that task right let's
say you have 100 different models some
of them all some take a second to run
some take an hour to run if any one of
those single models fails your entire
airflow task will fail right and you
wouldn't know which one failed until the
end of the execution and if you wanted
to rerun just one single model that
failed you would end up rerunning all of
them because it would just be your whole
project at once so what this shows is a
way to run one task per DBT model
basically making your airflow dag match
your DBT DAC
in the contents of the Manifest that it
uses here is that same nodes depends on
key that I showed you earlier so here's
a little preview of like what this looks
like on the left is code that I just
literally copied from the blog article
um you don't have to kind of read
through all of that but you can see
things where those those keys that we
were talking about before the nodes
depends on you can see those going
through for loops and such and kind of
circling the same Contents I showed you
there and then on the right side is an
example of what this airflow dag looks
like if you were to open up your DBT doc
site your airflow dag would look very
similar now we get dependencies between
all of these things
okay so a building on top of that this
inspires something that we ended up
building at Squarespace
um and uh very similar kind of idea
right like a lot of the code was taken
straight from that article with some
kind of like specifics to like the
context of you know our organization and
that's kind of always how things happen
right if you have to build something at
your place there's always different
nuancing context there
um and so you know the implementation of
this was again very similar but the
reason why we needed this um was you
know for the same reasons that I showed
that I just discussed earlier about
instead of having one task you now have
multiple tasks you have better
observability into your task failure
re-running but a little bit deeper into
why we needed to do this is that airflow
is the orchestration tool at Squarespace
I didn't have a choice in that right
um and it's kind of already there it's
already built we're building DBT stuff
but the the users who are using DBT uh
shouldn't really have to know airflow
and have to deal with airflow right we
have a lot of analysts and analytics
Engineers data scientists uh writing DVT
models it all works nice right they can
run on their machines they can they can
test things
um but you know we don't want to have
them to go into have them go into the
airflow change all the airflow python
code just to update things
um so you know basically that was kind
of my job is to build this
infrastructure so that way they don't
have to do that but also what we did is
we extended the DBT operation so not
only just you know running a model you
could now automatically have a test task
immediately after your run task all the
time we were creating external tables uh
sometimes in certain use cases so these
are all things that were kind of like
custom to what our workflows needed
needed and we would just add those
automatically into the dag without
people having to kind of write those
tasks themselves there are some things
like custom alerting for individual
models you could we we then added tags
inside of the model files or inside of
the yaml where you can say alert this
lock Channel this model fails or if this
group of model fails but it can all run
in the same dag so you wouldn't have to
set up like multiple dags to make the
airflow more complex
uh so this is kind of what it looks like
that's the name of the class was this
dag Builder
um and of course I'm obfuscating some of
the task names not that it's like
terribly sensitive
um but there's an example here of just
on the top right two models that run
right there's some uh there's no really
dependencies between them but we have a
sentinel start Task then we have all of
our DB tests TBT tasks in the middle
there's a run task there and the
external table task comes immediately
after and then we have a sentinel end
task so these start and end tasks are
actually really important and really
helpful because if that dag is doing
anything besides DBT you can then have
something Upstream that runs like if you
want to test tasks before the start or
if you want to like have a docs task
after the end or even non-dbt operations
you can kind of now mix your DVT
execution into some other dag that's
doing other things then the bottom here
is an example of like you know one big
dag where there's not really any
dependencies between the models we have
other ones now with hundreds of of tasks
and dependencies but I wasn't able to
grab that screenshot
okay one one other aspect on this this
is the deepest that I'm going to go into
any of these use cases
um you know beyond just like what do we
do with the Manifest file how do we read
it and how do we parse the dag is like
how do you actually keep this dag up to
date right because what airflow does is
it runs your kind of dag file your
python file constantly all the time to
make sure and pick up any changes in uh
the dag structure and so
you know there was a couple options for
this right it's like you know we were
using cicd you know practices and
feature branches and then merges to the
main branch
um what we ended up going was with this
first option actually was um dynamically
like updating the airflow dag during the
dag parsing so what that meant is that
anytime somebody changed the DBT project
code we had to push that to airflow and
we already had mechanisms internally for
the airflow uh it was on kubernetes they
are flow pods getting the files up to
date so the files were kind of already
up to date but DBT again the Manifest
file because we're reading the Manifest
file to understand the structure of the
airflow dag we needed to make sure to
update that manifest file and to update
that manifest file you have to execute
DBT and to execute DBT you have to
connect to your Warehouse so this
actually takes you know a few seconds
sometimes like 20 seconds to a minute to
compile your project so we had a lot of
airflow settings that we had to tweak to
kind of get that right because airflow
dag parsing usually assumes that it
takes like just like a couple seconds
um and then one other aspects we had
here as far as like environment
separations we made sure to execute DBT
in an isolated virtual environment so
that way the python environment for
airflow wasn't conflicting with the DBT
environment
um
and the reason that we did this so This
is actually the second option is way
easier so let me go into that first and
say why we did the first one second
option is a lot easier because
um if you just upload your artifacts
that you're at build time so when a main
branch merges you can upload a Json file
just like S3 writer GCS and then pull it
down when you need it in airflow
um that's actually really easy to do
right because this is an artifact of DBT
you can move that single Json file
around and it has the exact description
of your project the problem why we
didn't go with this option is sometimes
in our dag structure we wanted to only
execute a subset of our DBT project
we're using select or exclude so we say
we're going to run these certain models
twice a day and all the rest of the
models run once a day those need to be
in different dags and that dag Builder
class now needs to just select those so
if we needed to cut up our DVT project
it was a lot harder to do that from the
Json file itself because those dbts
select and exclude statements are very
complex right there's like set
operations group operations you can
select tags you can exclude things you
can ask things for that are Downstream
of a node or Upstream so we would have
had to rebuild all that selection if we
were going to do this second option so
we ended up both were going to be a lot
of work we ended up doing the work too
actually just execute DBT inside of the
airflow environment
okay so that was like the deepest I was
I'm gonna go into anything that went
like Beyond DBT that went into airflow a
little bit so hopefully I can kind of
bring you back and talk about a little
bit uh more use cases but that was just
something that was uh really fun to
build so I just couldn't help myself
like talking about that all right next
category we have here is uh developer
experience so we'll go into one more uh
Squarespace example and then I promise
there's more uh Community ones here
um and so this is so when we talk about
developer experience right we're talking
about like how can people uh build most
efficiently and make sure that their
code is correct uh as quickly as
possible Right prevent failures as soon
as possible and so one way you do this
is through you know continuous
integration continuous deployment
practices right DBT has ways for you to
kind of uh do uh what are they called uh
it's like like through CI like slimci
executing your project and things like
that so you know the typical way that
you would think about is somebody writes
some code on their machine they test it
it works uh before you merge it into
your your main branch you want to make
sure that you execute this somewhere in
a production environment the problem
that comes in when we're talking about
data is that sometimes that execution of
the on the production environment will
take an hour to run right and you don't
want to wait an hour for every single
model to run every time you want to
change like one single character in your
code so one thing that we ended up doing
that um
so it turned out like really well to
kind of like help with this is executing
dry runs so we're using bigquery and
trino and both of these support dry runs
and I think other warehouses would
support it as well and so in bigquery
it's actually called a dry run and so
what this is is it'll take a query and
it'll basically do the work to build the
query plan but it won't execute the
query and so it's first of all it's
really fast
and then second of all it's going to
know if a table doesn't exist if a
column name is wrong or if your SQL
syntax is wrong so that's typically most
of the time what goes wrong to break a
SQL statement right otherwise it'll run
it might still be wrong the output but
at least we can catch if there's
something wrong like you know it's just
like when you're dealing with a lot of
people who might be new to a system it's
like you know you're supposed to run
code anytime you change it but you know
that doesn't always happen right
sometimes people are in a rush so we
want to make sure that we're always
executing it and uh so you know that's
what we did so from the Manifest file we
took that we could get the compiled SQL
basically you know the real SQL that DBT
would run we pass all that through to
bigquery and just do a dry run on all of
it you know like multi-thread and so it
happens really fast so now every time
somebody changes code every single model
now gets a dry run you catch it anytime
there's like a syntax error
um one one kind of nuance to this is
that let's say you're introducing two
new models in your new Change Model A
and model B model B depends on Model A
if you're using the compiled code the
model B SQL is going to try to select
from Model A but Model A because this is
development doesn't yet exist in your
production database so when it tries to
run that it would fail so the way that
we worked around this is that we
actually I would actually copy the whole
DBT project into a temporary place
and then add a config line to the end of
every single SQL model force them all to
be ephemeral which if you're not
familiar with DPT there's different
materialization strategies which means
like oh this model is going to create a
table in the warehouse where this model
is going to create a view
ephemeral means don't actually create a
table but just take this SQL and inject
it as a CTE in your Downstream model so
what this does now every single SQL file
for every model is now self-contained
and it'll be able to run all the
Upstream models as ctes inside of them
again it's not running them in the dry
runs it's just doing syntax checking and
things like that so it actually makes
that really nice the only problem that
we run into is that bigquery has a limit
to the complexity of your queries so if
you have a big chain of a lot of
different models it just like won't flat
out won't run the query so there's like
nothing you can do I'm hoping somebody
there solves that because I'm not there
anymore
um and here's just like some code again
I wanted to be able to show it
um we're loading our manifest file with
that that function that I showed you
earlier up here and then inside of that
grabbing the compiled SQL path from the
target folder and then there's just like
the Nuance of like how DBT chooses to to
kind of
um save those files you read that as a
text file and then you pass it to the
bigquery client and the major key is to
make sure you pass this dry run
parameter as true otherwise it's going
to try to actually execute the query
which could take a long time an
additional thing that we did was to make
a separate service account that was not
the Production Service account that
didn't have read write access to the
destinations so that way you don't
accidentally write to your to your
database when you don't want to and then
on the right there we can show the dry
run succeeding probably should have
showed it failing so you could actually
see that because like that's the main
benefit to it but if it fails the
bigquery API or our client has like a
really nice kind of like failure
messages which will tell you what's
wrong you change it push it back up then
it should be good
so it's examples of things that I didn't
build
um I went to coalesce 2021 virtually
yeah that one was a virtual I didn't go
to 2022 so these examples are like a
year-ish old and it was at like the end
of 2021 so it's not that old I know like
things move fast in this world but
hopefully this stuff still is applicable
um so there's this talk that I watched
from Darren at AutoTrader
um and they were doing uh basically they
were using DBT metadata to enforce uh
kind of best practices and rules at
their organization and so this is really
cool right so you can see here there's
this meta key on that yaml on the right
you can add whatever you want to this in
this case they were showing who the
owner was and there's this other tag
called Model maturity which I thought
was really cool so you could still kind
of like develop and test and iterate on
models but you can say hey this isn't
prod don't use this in your dashboards
don't show this to the CEO yet
um but you can still kind of have it in
the warehouse for people to play around
with
um and they basically enforced contracts
between teams by using this metadata it
was all documented in one place and then
they had CI CD checks to make sure that
every single model had these meta tags
so that way everything would always be
documented you couldn't make any changes
or add any new models unless this was
there so again this is ways to enforce
quality to make sure people know help
documentation so that's all helps kind
of this world developer experience I'm
going to take a quick sip of water while
you ponder that
okay we got two more
um the next one I'm going to talk about
is external configuration and this is I
don't have as many examples on this
because I'm I'm not that creative I
guess
um but this is something one of those
things where it's like I want to just
seed this idea in your head that you can
use DBT to configure things that aren't
DBT
um so here's one I think it's just one
example that I have yeah one example
also from coalesce this is Tegan from
community.com showed how they use the
Manifest to do this exact thing
configuring external systems so the
example that I have here on the screen
was uh for slack alerting right so they
actually use those same meta tags that I
showed you in the previous slide and you
would put like the slack channel of who
needs to be alerted when this model
fails and then you know whatever system
you have to execute whether it's airflow
or not can know okay we have to now send
this slack alert and so there we're
building a system that reads that and
then now there's some micro service
that's sitting there it's consuming the
Manifest file anytime that gets updated
and then it's deciding oh do I need to
send a slack alert right now yes or no
and it's doing all that work there and
so like the the big kind of like
mind-blowing part for this for me is
that you can build a micro service that
reads your DBT project and does whatever
you want right and so again in keeping
people in their best tools you can now
have people who wouldn't be the kinds of
person who's writing a microservice to
send slack alerts or to update data or
send things into another system
but now can control and configure those
systems right and so that's like uh the
main idea and like I said I wasn't kind
of creative enough to come up with other
ones because I never had to do this at
my job but hopefully you can kind of
think about this and maybe come to the
office hours and we can brainstorm some
other ideas later
okay uh the last section here is
observability and this is going to go a
little bit beyond the Manifest but you
know it ties into the artifacts in
general so I think it's kind of uh in in
the same vein
okay uh so the first part uh I really
like this package is called the DBT
artifacts package it's actually a DVT
package so you would install it uh with
DBT and this is fun and I was supposed
to put the exhibit meme where he's like
you know I like use DBT on your DBT I
don't know that's kind of dating me a
little bit and my humor
um
but what this does is it takes all those
DBT artifacts that I showed you as files
right the Json file there's like a Run
results there's like a message like
other stuff and it actually creates
models in your project that will write
that data to your Warehouse so you're
going to have and and the top right here
is actually the uh the DBT docs you know
dag there and you can you can go see an
example of Brooklyn data manages this
and and they have it uh up up on their
GitHub and they have the doc site live
that you can see
um and so what this does is it it puts
those in your Warehouse right so like
maybe you don't want to write a python
function like like I did and you don't
need to write a python function that
reads that you know generates airflow
tags but you wanted to like you know see
how many models are in your project
right you're managing this for a bunch
of people and you need to make sure like
are people you know doing things right
you know which data sources are they
reading from all of those things again
anything that your DBT project has will
be in these artifacts and then these
artifacts are now in your warehouse for
you to query and to do your analytics
engineering on top of right
um I I showed you a screenshot here of
one of the macros that actually pulls
this data so technically it's not using
the manifest.json file but it's using
the same contents from that uh in later
versions of DBT what they have available
are these uh is this graph object and I
didn't Circle it but like on the third
line you can see four node in
graph.nodes that graph is a ginger
template I think is what they what the
technical term is but like that's
available in all of your Macros and all
of your Jinja that's basically the
Manifest essentially but in a ginger
python object so in this case they're
pulling all of those things and then
they're creating models to to kind of
run and save the contents into tables in
your warehouse and then you can kind of
read those and do whatever you want with
them it's pretty cool
and so like on this vein of
observability like DBT artifacts allows
you to kind of save all that contents
into your warehouse but that's kind of
where it ends right that it's still in
part of your DBT project uh so there's
this uh open source in the startup
called Elementary data that basically
does the same thing as DBT artifacts it
captures all that data into your
warehouse but then it takes that and
starts to do things with it like kind of
like for you right it'll do like uh
visualizations of what your project
looks like and just monitoring and
alerting showing you when things change
showing you when things Break
um all of those things and I haven't dug
like super deep into kind of what this
tool does this again just mostly an
example of like what's possible with the
Manifest and so you could kind of check
out that project and check out that
company too
um but I think it's really cool right
because it's again it's like the power
that you have as like somebody working
in this field starts with the data right
and so we're getting kind of meta about
this right we're getting data about the
things that we're doing doing to make
our data but it's just a data project
like anything else and you can get all
kinds of information that you might need
to know to make sure that your data
pipelines are kind of like up to date
understand what's failing understand
what's wrong understand technical debt
all those things
okay uh so those are all of the like
deep dive examples that there's like too
many applications for me to count and
kind of like fit into this deck and
honestly I didn't spend too much time
preparing uh too much uh more time to
kind of like
um add examples for for all of these but
I'm going to leave that as homework for
you all
um another observability tool is called
read data uh they do similar things I
think as Elementary data don't quote me
on that
um but they kind of you know read the
man the the DPT artifacts and and do
observability
um there's a cool vs code extension if
anybody uses VX code for your DBT code
called DBT power user it does like
autocomplete and kind of like make sure
your DBT syntax is correct and there's a
lot of other nice stuff for you locally
that also reads the DBT artifacts and
the Manifest
um and there's this project called DBT
osmosis and I didn't do a super deep
dive into it because I haven't seen uh
updates on it in the last few months but
it's a pretty cool tool and idea I
didn't run it but it does like automated
automated code refactoring of your
project so you think about like your DBT
project is going to have a lot of yaml
files with a lot of docs and you have to
write every single column out and write
descriptions for it it helps you kind of
like handle that well and of course it
reads the artifacts because the
artifacts describe your project
um
cool okay so I always like to do a quick
recap because I threw a lot of
information at you
um basically the Manifest is your friend
you should use it you should look at it
build stuff on top of it you can use
Python you could write it to your
warehouse and then you can just use SQL
to analyze it
um and some of the use cases I went
through is like the airflow
orchestration making your airflow dag
match your DBT dag project testing or
developer experience right to make sure
that you know your code is going to run
in your Warehouse make sure you're
following organizational best practices
other examples are kind of external
configuration right like the slack
alerts that I mentioned or ways that you
can kind of kind of tell other systems
and build microservices on top of your
project as well as observability to
understand the health of your DBT
project how things are running
and you can contact me again riktur
anywhere if you have any questions I'll
have the office hours after lunch
um but besides that I can probably have
some time for questions now and thank
you
[Music]